did you see this story today in the
paper that this uh BB rexa was up on
stage live and a fan threw a telephone
at her and hit her right in her eye I
mean she's okay but that freaks me out
because and they they arrested the kid
who threw it and he said Oh I thought it
was funny then he should have let her
throw a telephone at his face then he
could experience that fun do you panic
about stuff like that when you're up on
stage you're so vulnerable yeah right oh
especially after what happened with
Jason Aldean like I I mean I literally
looked at Brandon that was when I was
still married and I was like I I don't
know when I'm gonna go back out like I'm
that you know because then you start
thinking like
I'm gonna risk that and like not see my
kids again because I was singing on
stage like you know I'm saying like it
becomes very silly and you know to even
question
why you would do that you know I'm
saying so it just I've also like at one
time I was singing at this thing and my
eyes were closed
and so you're even more vulnerable and
this person on live TV on this show
overseas rushed the stage and came up
and hugged me and put their arms around
me but like when your eyes are closed
and you're singing oh my God you you
aren't you aren't thinking anything
except I mean I had like a
I had like a whole moment that night at
the hotel like where people were like
are you okay and I just wasn't talking
and like if I'm not talking there's a
problem like yeah so it's um it was very
scary just like because you you I think
at that moment I realized how vulnerable
I was and I'd never thought like that
before and then what happened with Jason
and what happened just as shows people
are very angry and they are you know and
you don't want to get caught in that
Crossfire of anger
oh